here's the setup obviously this woman is
having a hysterical meltdown but this
guy is causing the hysterical meltdown
what he's saying is you flipped me off
in the road which is something that
happens virtually every time anybody
goes out driving right
someone will flip you off or give honk
the horn or that's that's in the nature
of driving it's road rage call it
whatever it's perfectly normal it's not
some racial incident and so he follows
this woman home she pulls into her
driveway he pulls in behind her gets out
and gets a camera in her face that is
very bad behavior that is forget it's
not chivalrous behavior that is
aggressive creepy like if anyone ever
did that to my wife then we're gonna
have more than a YouTube video to worry
about kind of behavior and yet he's
being portrayed as the victim here and
he even admits what's he worried about
he's upset because she flipped him off
and so now he's in her face and she's
freaking out now why is she freaking out
she might just be a hysterical woman but
I think she's probably freaking out
because she knows how this goes how this
has been going for the past few weeks is
you have a viral internet video out of
context accusing some white person of
committing a racism and whether there's
evidence for it or not that person's
life is ruined and the accuser faces no
consequences at all he actually
ironically uses a racial epithet it's
kind of a funny racial epithet it's one
that everyone is using in popular
culture now Karen but Karen does have a
racial quality to it in that it very
specifically refers to a busybody white
woman so he is getting in her face
imagine this imagine what a what a
degenerate man you would have to be to
have a woman becoming hysterical in
front of you a woman that you don't know
and you follow her home and get in her
face and yell insults at her what did
what a sick degenerate pervert you've
got to be to do that so he keeps this up
she keeps freaking out and having this
this meltdown and then he goes one step
further he decides to Doc's the woman
Karen are you okay can you explain to me
calmly I'm not attacking you ma'am you
flicked me off guys this is her
license-plate number she lives here
her dress Karen you flipped me off you
cut me off and flipped me off and now
you're playing the victim ma'am would
you like to calm down guys she flipped
me off
she literally flipped me off if this she
tried to come home
she's Karen Karen would you like to calm
down to have a conversation why you okay
he actually is attacking her here I know
it doesn't quite seem that way because
she's obviously becoming very hysterical
she's becoming hysterical for good
reason
the people who show up in these videos
get their lives ruined and what he is
saying why here's her license plate
here's where she lives is come get her
come get her mob uh it would be much
less threatening if he just punched her
in the face and walked away or like that
man in New York threw a firecracker on a
homeless person it would actually be
less threatening because what he's
saying here is here's where she is
here's where you can find her even when
she's in a car here's how you can find
her and you can ruin her life so I
actually think I'd like to think I would
not react in that way but it's perfectly
understandable that she is just judging
from this incident this guy is a sick
degenerate and I don't know if there are
laws against what he's doing where he is
daxing is against the law in many states
but if there aren't laws then there
should be laws and this guy should be
punished for what he did
then you google him and you find out
this guy it's all a setup it this wasn't
because she flipped him off or anything
he hates white people apparently his his
Twitter handle is why pepo hate why
people hate right yeah get it his name
is Carlos Dillard he's pulled this stunt
before he's accused people baselessly of
racism before he's tried to go viral he
considers himself an entertainer and a
comedian and an actor and all sorts of
things he's got all these websites on
the internet and he doesn't have a big
following at all but he's trying to go
viral on Twitter and I guess he did I
guess he did and he got what he wanted
cuz we're talking about it but of course
we're talking about it because it
trended that's that's what we are that's
what we are creating in this culture is
make-believe there there isn't racial
bigotry going on all over the place it
just isn't happening
there isn't a villain there isn't an
oppressor and so degenerates like Carlos
Dillard have to make it up we're all
making it up in this culture I don't
know
even mean just a single out him I want
to single him out because he behaved
horribly and should be punished by the
law for it but it's beyond him it's the
whole culture we should all we should
all rewrite reset our culture
[Music]
you